DUDE WITH A LOT OF TIME ON HIS
HANDS.
>> Juan: UP NEXT, HE MAY NOT
BE RUNNING, BUT HILLARY CLINTON,
SHE COULD HAVE A BIG IMPACT ON
2020.
SHE IS REPORTEDLY TEAMING UP
WITH ELIZABETH WARREN.
SHE IS ADVISING WARREN ON HOW TO
BEAT HER DEMOCRATIC RIVAL.
WHAT YOU THINK OF THAT QUESTION
MY >> I THINK THAT
ELIZABETH WARREN IS SO FAR LEFT
IN TERMS OF HER POLICY.
SHE HAS BEEN IN RECENT WEEKS,
REACHING OUT TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, SAYING, I'M A
UNITER.
I'M GOING TO WIN BACK THE SENATE
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
SHE'S TRYING TO WOO AND SOOTHE
PEOPLE'S CONCERNS.
>> Juan: WHAT'S THE PROBLEM
WITH REACHING OUT TO SOMEONE WHO
IS SO POPULAR AMONG DEMOCRATS?
IT WAS LIKE WHAT I THINK WAS
ROCKY FIVE.
WE DON'T NEED ANOTHER ROCKY.
AND THEN WE ENDED UP GETTING ONE
ON HBO.
I WOULD SAY THIS.
THIS IS HILLARY CLINTON SAYING,
HOWEVER THE WINNER IS, I THINK
PLEASE REMEMBER I WAS THERE IN
THE BEGINNING.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT
ELIZABETH WARREN WAS REACHING
OUT TO HILLARY CLINTON.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I MEAN, WHAT ARE HER BIG
POLITICAL STRATEGIES?
SHE RIGGED THE PRIMARIES AGAINST
BERNIE.
SHE LOST THE OTHER PRIMARY
AGAINST OBAMA.
SHE GOT WIPED OUT BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I WANT TO CALL HER, YOU KNOW.
>> Juan: HILLARY CLINTON HAS
PROVEN ABLE AS A CANDIDATE AMONG
BLACK VOTERS AND AMONG WOMEN
VOTERS.
I THINK ELIZABETH WARREN WOULD
LIKE TO GET BOTH OF THEM.
>> Dana: I THINK THIS IS A
SIGN OF STRENGTH OF
ELIZABETH WARREN PEERED SHE'S
ACTING LIKE A CANDIDATE.